another five minute game time player
from China right you don't see this too
often dumb what could I play on let's
let's try something here let's play the
blumenfeld gambit answer I think
probably never played this never played
the CM on video and I don't really know
the theory well maybe I played it once
or so but certainly not too often yeah
I'm in return for the porn like it's got
um very ammonius piece placement and
good good development nice central
control and play white is some getting
ready to UM to play e-form cow your form
yeah what should I play for some
positional positional threat if I cannot
really or maybe I can play a 5v5 if ID
for but then it can easily happen that
my pawns I lose some dynamism and then
it's just material down form for no
compensation
hmm I'm not sure what what what this
also does it weakens have to but I'm
wondering about the move c4 maybe it is
just terrible but c4e for Bishop c5 this
kind of idea okay I need to play at some
point getting getting at the F to pawn
it looks a bit weird the c-4 because the
bishop on a successor somewhat blocked
but ok the bishop on a 60 doesn't
fulfill any a useful role at the moment
anyway it was some preventing you for
for a while as long as the rook was on
f1 and locate captured this porn then
some some time you need to get the porn
back I'm not sure what if white should
really play you for now maybe Bishop c5
looks looks a bit a bit uncomfortable
getting at this pressure on them on f2
yeah it's um this is the principal move
of course yeah okay let's get the bishop
p.m. what and now this is not this is
not playable cannot believe this Bishop
f2 this can cannot be a character yeah I
can just take this for various reasons
I mean King f2a can play night before
and just it's a double check out a win
material but Queen B success is even
worse he doesn't turn he doesn't have
ever move really against this rookie 394
has curtains immediately and the King f
1 i've got c3 check and this is also a
complete disaster ya na g5 was some just
losing instantly but i think i'm not
sure if all it looks really dangerous to
me this position with the computer it
actually gives like a complete a winning
position here after Bishop c5 yeah I
thought it would be dangerous getting on
the sea on the F 2 square in general
accepting the gambit is some is okay for
white but it's very a tricky you can
easily lose them use loose quickly
probably it needs to do something else
here it's so some some other moves it's
it's not so easy to suggest move so the
black hat Scott really an easy play for
and especially in a blitz game where you
need to yeah need the wrong word but you
welcome easy these decisions just
developing putting pieces forward and
not defending your wife needs a good
defense of mafia not sure
move that you maybe would like to play
sb3 to attack the pawns but then this
move enter and have a look at this like
something like this looks overwhelming
for black yeah I'm not sure maybe white
needs to play something else one one
thing that I that I saw before is that
white plays ab32 maybe this is a plate
b3 to prevent the sea formals and this
is actually ok for black I don't know a
big disaster for her for white and nice
to win some game quickly thanks for
watching